[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica siete días
aquí el francés 24 este es un magazine
informativo dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es malva norman y
estos son los titulares el mes sagrado
del ramadán ha comenzado para los
musulmanes pero este año la guerra en
ucrania ha disparado los precios de los
alimentos lo que ensombrece las
celebraciones mientras francia se alista
para elegir su próximo presidente
veremos cuál es el balance de las
políticas del presidente en manuel marco
hacia el continente africano y ya se
conocen las cinco selecciones africanas
que participarán en el mundial de
qatar-2022 para representar al
continente africano
analizamos sus emparejamientos con
nuestro especialista en deportes rodrigo
ciudadano
el mes de ramadán sagrado para los
musulmanes comenzó este sábado 2 de
abril tradicionalmente los fieles ayunan
desde el amanecer hasta el atardecer
mientras que las cenas suelen ser
festivas y compartidas con toda la
familia pero este año el aumento de los
precios en varios países eclipsó la
festividad este disparo de los costos es
la consecuencia de la guerra en ucrania
aunque ésta no es la única causa veamos
la situación en senegal
en este mercado de dakar la capital
senegalesa el ambiente es algo sombrío
mientras que el mes del ramadán acaba de
empezar los precios de los alimentos no
dejan de subir los fieles acostumbradas
a romper el ayuno con fastuosas comidas
familiares tienen ahora dificultades
para comprar productos básicas antes de
gastar aun comparan y su pesan en
realidad nada es accesible todos los
alimentos son caros antes de entrar a
una bolsa de vegetales por 13 dólares
pero hoy me cuesta entre 25 y 33 dólares
y es lo mismo para todos los productos
aunque todos los años los precios suben
al acercarse al pedido del ramadán este
año la inflación se ha incrementado más
debido a la pandemia del cob y 19 y a la
guerra de ucrania
para algunos ciudadanos se suman las
sanciones impuestas por la comunidad
económica de estados de áfrica
occidental contra el vecino madre
el cierre de la frontera maliense ha
empeorado las cosas porque hay productos
que se pegan no tienen y que salen de
guinea malí
inevitablemente hay que pasar por mal y
antes de llegar a senegal
el pasado mes de septiembre el gobierno
senegalés anunció varias medidas para
intentar frenar la subida de precios
como por ejemplo la reducción de los
derechos de aduana de algunos productos
pero hoy estas medidas no parecen haber
dado resultados
el 26 de marzo en la ciudad francesa de
montpellier se dio una subasta
excepcional una máscara fong de gabón se
vendió por 4.2 millones de euros la obra
que data del siglo 19 es uno de los
pocos ejemplares que se conservan
todavía hablamos con ángel martín
especialista en arte antiguo africano a
quien le preguntamos qué es una máscara
fong y por qué ésta se vendió a un
precio tan elevado
y la verdad es que es sorprende porque
la cuantía es grande pero también hay
que decir que ni siquiera es la más cara
fan de este tipo máscara que se ha
vendido una máscara muy similar se
vendió hace unos años no hace muchos en
parís el nuevo opel y en parís en 6
millones de euros era una máscara del
mismo tipo una máscara de la sociedad
de los fans me pregunta qué es una
máscara fans pues es una máscara que
perteneció a una cofradía religiosa y
social que se llamaba en guild de un
grupo los fans y vivían en gabón en
camerún y guinea ecuatorial y que aunque
siguen viviendo en estas regiones en la
década de los 10 y de los años 20 del
siglo pasado del siglo 20 perdieron sus
digamos instituciones tradicionales
religiosas políticas
y entrar en otro tipo de religiones
local es africanas pero no autóctonas de
ellos y en otro tipo de religiones
foráneas como pueden ser el cristianismo
o el islam
lo cierto es que máscaras en guild a día
de hoy no se conocen más de 10 hasta que
sea subastado en un pelín es bellísima
no hay más de 10 12 la mitad de ellas en
colecciones públicas en museos y la otra
mitad en manos privadas eso justifica el
que el precio de mercado de estas
máscaras pues estén en estos cuatro
millones doscientos o trescientos mil
euros en los que se ha vendido esta los
seis millones en las que se vendió la
última subasta de la penúltima subasta
de la última serie
la subasta fue interrumpida por
activistas que consideran que los
objetos de arte deben ser restituidos a
sus países de origen y que la máscara
tiene que regresar a gabón pero los
organizadores de la venta afirman que
habían advertido sobre la subasta al
estado gabonés y aseguran que no
recibieron ninguna respuesta
preguntamos al especialista porque según
las autoridades del país africano no
reaccionaron
fácil yo podría decir que es fácil
interrumpir una subasta y
presentarse como activista o militante
de la destitución de los sujetos
africanos es una doctrina plenamente
aceptable y plenamente respetable
pero que el problema
realmente no están todos y el gobierno
de libreville pudiera estar interesado
en la institución de esta máscara min
usted cuando estamos delante de un bien
cultural que vale en el mercado 4 2
millones 5 millones de euros el problema
no es el problema que se plantea no es
la restitución
rápida y pasional a una región
geográfica concreta del globo el
problema es el compromiso que la
sociedad y las sociedades tienen que
tener en el
como diríamos la conservación de este
objeto porque hay 10 hay 12 máscaras
como mucho de este tipo en todo el mundo
en los 5 continentes entre colecciones
públicas y colecciones privadas no
además que 12 cuando hay 12 ejemplares
de una obra de arte magnética cómo está
el problema que las sociedades tienen
que plantearse es la conservación el
conocimiento y la divulgación y eso
solamente se puede hacer a través de una
institución como puede ser un museo
pedir a la institución es fácil pero
darle las garantías a un bien cultural
de esta dimensión
no es tan fácil no sé si el gobierno de
libreville o no francamente lo
desconozco es esta
en estas condiciones pero que lo
ciertamente preocupante es que seamos
capaces de garantizar el futuro para
bienes artísticos para aviones de la
entidad de esta máscara fauna el llamado
a la reconciliación tras la
conmemoración del final de la guerra de
argelia la retirada de las fuerzas
francesas de malí o la devolución de
objetos de arte a bening son sólo
algunos de los hitos que marcaron el
tono de las relaciones del presidente
francés emmanuel marco con las ex
colonias del país europeo
manuela canon nos cuenta cuál es el
balance de la política africana de mayo
mientras que francia se alista para
elegir su próximo presidente
las relaciones con áfrica ocuparon un
papel central en los cinco años de
mandato de manuel marco recién
posesionado el presidente francés
prometía un profundo viraje ahora sus
aciertos y errores podrían influir en su
imagen como líder mayor buscó demostrar
una cierta modernidad buscó dialogar con
la juventud africana y buscó gente e
insistir en su juventud en el hecho de
que él no había conocido la del tiempo
de la colonización pero ha sido
problemático porque hubo sea estas
fuertes adicciones contradicciones que
se vieron reflejadas en la presencia de
militares franceses en sus ex colonias
africanas a pesar del retiro de las
fuerzas en mali francia no abandona su
influencia militar en el sahel o
salvárcar e no se va a ver de malí
porque los franceses lo pidan porque los
malienses lo pidan sabar cannes se va de
malí porque es una operación que no
funciona que no tiene resultados de
naturaleza de la barca no es cosa es
controvertida es decir
se ven de que hay una serie de grupos
terroristas pero desde la población
local la palabra terrorista no existe en
las lenguas locales la carrera al elíseo
se da en medio de una importante y tula
conmemoración del aniversario de los 60
años del fin de la guerra en argelia a
cuyos ex combatientes marco buscó
reconocer y reparar una buena parte de
los electores bien oa los pies negros es
decir
franceses nacidos en argelia que han
tenido que volver de volverse para la
metrópolis que van a participar en las
elecciones constituyen pues una parte
importante pero tampoco es el
insignificante del electorado en plena
campaña electoral los candidatos toman
el peso del imaginario francés sobre sus
ex colonias como bandera para los
candidatos de derecha el de extrema
derecha al temas centrales el tema de la
migración estos candidatos insisten en
no recibir no va a flagrantes que
provienen del continente africano un
punto a los candidatos de izquierda hay
sobre todo a una voluntad de ruptura con
la acción solubilidad del
intervencionismo militar de formación el
próximo líder francés se enfrentará no
sólo a las heridas del pasado colonial
sino también a los retos del futuro un
continente dolido en la era post
pandemia por haber sido relegado en la
vacunación y en el que cada vez más
otras potencias como china y rúsia ganan
influencia
pasamos al fútbol para abordar el
próximo mundial de qatar al término de
la repesca para la zona africana cinco
selecciones se han clasificado entre los
54 candidatos para al continente nuestro
experto en deportes nos explicó por qué
hay una polémica en la clasificación
africana al mundial y cuáles son los
emparejamientos de estos equipos en
qatar ya se conocen el nombre y los
emparejamientos de 29 de las 32
selecciones que formarán parte del
próximo mundial de qatar-2022 entre
ellas los cinco combinados africanos
clasificados se tratan de ghana
marruecos túnez camerún y senegal esta
última actual campeona de la copa áfrica
clasificó reeditando la victoria que le
dio el título continental frente a
egipto mal año futbolístico para los
egipcios que con esta eliminación
abrieron de nuevo la polémica en torno a
los cupos africanos a los mundiales de
fútbol tienen siete títulos
continentales en su haber y tan sólo
cuentan con dos participaciones
mundialistas en áfrica y solamente cinco
plazas en una eliminatoria de 54
naciones y un 92 por ciento de
probabilidad de clasificarse en un
continente donde cada vez hay más
igualdad entre las mejores selecciones
en comparación con la región
suramericana tienen 4 pues fijos más uno
por repesca para días elecciones
nacionales 13 en europa también para 54
países en el sorteo senegal quedó
seleccionada al grupo a junto al
anfitrión qatar países bajos y ecuador a
priori un buen grupo para conseguir
pasar a la siguiente fase países bajos
está lejos de su mejor momento y ecuador
clasificó como cuarta con luces pero
dejando dudas en suramérica en el grupo
de túnez se enfrentará a francia
dinamarca y al ganador de la repesca
entre emiratos árabes unidos australia o
perú marruecos pese a que su juego ha
ido mejorando tiene a priori un grupo
difícil con bélgica croacia dos
selecciones fuertes y canadá cambiaron
quedó emparejada compras y el suiza y
serbia en el grupo g y gana se
enfrentará a portugal uruguay y corea
del sur
la artista de jazz o me celebra la
música y el activismo de la cantante
sudafricana miriam makeba
interpretando varios de sus grandes
éxitos miriam makeba falleció en 2008 y
es un icono de la lucha contra el
apartheid vivió en el exilio durante
décadas y encarnó el espíritu de todo el
continente en su batalla contra la
injusticia social y la colonización
cerramos este programa con una de las
canciones de maqueda interpretada por
sony
[Música]
y gracias por acompañarnos y sigan con
nosotros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom